no but it's something happened maybe
something he's not talking about
something happened I agree like me I
quit drinking recently cuz something
happened to me me too what happened me
too what what happened it was bad what
happened BR what happened driving no you
got cocked no no never okay not never a
God damn he was big as [__] the what
happened you're not going to tell us cuz
you look tell yeah tell us what happened
it ain't enough alcohol in the world for
me to get cooked okay good good what
happened to make you change just stop
drinking in G you just D I was in I was
in Vegas and I got so [__]
drunk that I got robbed at thong Point
damn you're in a th by some by some
girls by stripper yeah damn Happ is the
best of us dog man she got me for almost
$200,000 worth of [__] what the what she
sh was hot though huh sh was hot as [__]
yeah I get it what hot as [__] wait what
did you have on my jewelry and [__] she
said give me that [__] and gave it to
Jake Paul yeah she probably gave [__] to
Jake Paul damn yeah
damn that make you sober up though 200k
in the in the the hole make you so up
yeah man I said [__] that I ain't never
want to drink after here now I never get
I'm like I'm never getting drunk again I
haven't Dr my biggest test going to be
uh New Year's in um Japan I'm going to
watch one aeta defend his belt and risen
oh that'd be dope oh dude how about
Bellator selling the pfl yeah [__] how
do you feel about it you're a Bellator
guy I what I mean your UFC got mainly
and pride got I the first I one of the
first ones to go with Bellator how do
you feel about it I don't give a [__]
about Bellator yeah sure yeah wait
selling there's a lot more there what
selling it to who bellor sold to pfl so
pfl oh they all own the same yeah so pfl
owns and they're all Saudi money so pfl
owns Bellator now so you're going to
have they're still going to do Bellator
then you're going to do a like basically
Super Bowl of Bellator fighter Champions
versus pfl Champions like once a year
it's interesting they're still not
touching the UFC U is so big man no UFC
is Coca-Cola everybody else is josta
yeah hey how did you know what I meant
when I said I got robbed at thong point
a lot of people don't why else would you
be in a thong dog I wasn't in a thong
she was in a thong oh my bad dog what
[__] you think this is think I'm a cook
and wearing a I thought that would so
you up if you're in a
thong no way I'm going to my why would
he have a thong on though he's a freak
DG